remise d'un rapport sur une question
personnelle et universelle
nous avons mené 31 auditions nous avons
écouté beaucoup d'acteurs de
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
cette loi qui a déjà 7 ans
n'avait jamais été évalué par des
parlementaires
force de constater qu'il y a aujourd'hui
des situations douloureuses et qui ne
sont pas suffisamment bien prises en
charge
bonjour je suis Olivier falornier député
de la Charente-Maritime et je préside la
mission d'évaluation de la loi sur la
fin de vie dite loi kless Leonetti
pendant deux mois nous avons suivi
Olivier Falorni dans sa mission
hôpital de Juvisy en région parisienne
une des unités de soins palliatifs
visités par Olivier Falorni
bonjour madame il en existe 170 en
France avec deux autres députés ils vont
évaluer si la façon dont on meurt
aujourd'hui dans notre pays est
acceptable
bienvenue Didier Martin qui rapportait
la France s'est dotée de quatre lois sur
la fin de vie la dernière date de 2016
notre rôle c'est évalué l'application de
la loi kless Leonetti donc voir les
failles éventuelles ce que nous voulons
c'est comment faire en sorte que
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie soit
le plus doux possible le plus
respectueux possible
un simple inventaire du
service majeur
charge de la fin de
vie de médecins s'occupaient des délits
de soins palliatifs de praticiens
hospitalier est en plein alors de
praticiens c'est en théorie c'est ce
qu'on devrait dans la vraie vie elle est
toute seule et encore elle s'occupe
d'une autre unité dans l'étage
côté infirmière en disant les effectifs
ont fondu quand tu arrives ici il y
avait beaucoup plus de soignants il y
avait aucun patient qui décidait seul
quand il y avait un patient qui était
voilà en train de partir on se détachait
petit à petit ce nombre il a diminué
maintenant on est deux par jour deux
infirmières par jour j'enlève mon masque
maintenant quand il y a un patient qui
est en train de partir c'est difficile
de se détacher
parce que la collègue reste toute seule
pour 10 patients persiste ce sentiment
de ne pas faire son travail correctement
ce matin une patiente a tout à coup
montré des signes de tristesse
il faut qu'on passe très souvent parce
qu'on voit qu'elle est bien avec quand
il y a quelqu'un
ce matin il n'était pas bien on a fini
la toilette on est parti on est revenu
même pas on a fait juste une toilette
elle était décédée c'est dans peut-être
il serait mieux décédé si elle avait
quelqu'un à côté d'elle peut-être
qu'elle pourrait même mourir avec le
sourire quoi et moi ça ça m'a fait mal
au cœur ce matin
je voulais vous poser une question très
directe est-ce qu'il y a des situations
où malgré tout les douleurs sont
réfractaires à tout traitement
en phase terminale quand le patient
souffre trop la loi clef et auditi à
introduit un laisser mourir sans
permettre le faire mourir est-ce que
vous pratiquez régulièrement ou pas
ce nouveau droit qui est celui de la
sédation profonde jusqu'au décès
une souffrance on est obligé à un
certain stade de passer aux pratiques de
l'acidation la sédation consiste à
endormir un malade et à ne plus le
nourrir ni l'hydrater jusqu'au décès
mais parfois ils n'en finit plus de
mourir une situation pas toujours bien
vécue par les familles une des limites
de la loi
vous avez le fruit de la décision
patient conscient cancer mes tests
terminale très douloureux etc les
proches sont informés ils passent un
moment ensemble
on se dit au revoir on est en place la
sédation
si au bout de trois jours les choses
sont toujours stables malades d'or ne
souffre pas trop qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous continuez ou vous augmentez
les dossiers si le patient est stable on
dépasse pas les doses nécessaires on va
pas forcer à partir du moment où le
patient il est confortable et que aucun
signe de souffrance
pendant quel but en fait ça peut durer
certains temps ça peut être Disney ça
nous est déjà arrivé des familles qui me
le demandent vous pouvez pas faire
quelque chose
pousser les seringues non désolé ils
auront pas de réponse favorable les
chaînes
ici on utilise que trois à quatre fois
la sédation chaque année sur les 200
passions accueillis et une autorisation
à l'aide active à mourir semble
impensable moi injecter un produit de
létal j'aurais mauvaise conscience
c'est pas à moi à donner la mort à
quelqu'un alors que moi j'ai signé pour
prendre soin de l'autre et pas pour le
faire mourir peut-être que la loi
évoluera vers suicide assisté pourquoi
pas le lieu des soins palliatifs en tout
cas l'hospitalisation sont qualitatif ne
sera pas forcément le lieu
c'est ce message là qu'on essaie
beaucoup facile parce que nous notre
mission n'est pas celle-là en tout cas
pour l'instant
pourtant du côté des patients cette
demande d'étendre la loi existe les
députés ne verront qu'un seul malade du
service mes spontanément c'est lui-même
qui va aborder ce sujet avec eux
bonjour Monsieur Olivier falorny donc
nous sommes députés tous les deux
est-ce qu'il y a des moments où vous
sentez que vous souffrez trop
est-ce que vous pensez que il faudrait
faire une loi pour les personnes qui
sont dans la même situation que vous
quelle loi il faudrait faire
si elle décide quoi Monsieur particulier
qu'on vous aide à partir
je suis vraiment en sécurité
dans le débat les représentants des
soins palliatifs ont toujours combattu
les partisans de l'aide activa mourir
une opposition qui n'aurait pas lieu
d'être selon le député
les soins palliatifs doivent être
confortés dans ce pays et s'il devait y
avoir une loi
ouvrant le droit à l'aide d'activer à
mourir pour autant il faudrait si j'ose
dire dans le même temps
conforter et renforcer
l'accompagnement en soins palliatifs en
donnant des moyens humains et financiers
et c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
en Belgique quand le pays a autorisé
l'euthanasie il y a 20 ans il a dans le
même temps renforcer ses services de
soins palliatifs
bonjour madame Olivier
de la Charente-Maritime
rencontre avec des professionnels qui
interviennent au domicile des passions
une prise en charge qui a augmenté ces
dernières années
l'accompagnement sans palliatifs il ne
se fait pas que en structure
hospitalière il se fait aussi dans les
lieux de vie et c'est ce que nous
voulions pouvoir échanger avec vous
aujourd'hui donc merci de nous
accueillir
nous sommes mis en pratique cet accès à
domicile n'est pas assez développé
d'abord parce qu'il demande une grande
disponibilité des proches mais pas
seulement quand on va or les murs de
l’hôpital ça devient hyper compliqué les
équipes mobiles de gériatrie d'accord
les dispositifs
polypathologies
ressources régionales les équipes
ressources nationales les filières de
gériatrie est-ce que c'est pas un des
rôles des élus de la nation de
simplifier l'accès et l'accessibilité et
l'actionnabilité pour les Français
85% des Français disent vouloir mourir
chez eux cependant une sédation par
exemple n'est quasiment pas réalisable à
domicile
minimum deux fois par jour pour évaluer
la situation tous les jours qu'ils
soient disponible 24 heures sur 24 et je
vous parle pas des médecins traitants
qui doivent exister être partie prenante
être disponible venir tous les jours et
être disponible 24 heures sur 24 en fait
la problématique elle est là résultat
plus on approche de la mort plus le
maintien à la maison sera rifie et c'est
souvent dans les services de médecine
générale que ces fins de vie se
produisent ce jour-là Olivier Falorni se
rend à l'hôpital de La Fontaine à
Saint-Denis au nord de Paris
un étage qui a été refait donc c'est un
service de médecine interne ici il y a
49 livres
dont ces services la loi classe Léonetti
est-elle adaptée une loi écrite après
l'affaire Vincent Lambert et la bataille
d'une famille autour du devenir d'un
homme dans un état végétatif une loi qui
a ainsi inventé les notions de
directives anticipées pour respecter la
volonté du patient quand celui-ci ne
peut plus s'exprimer
aujourd'hui est-ce que ces directives
anticipées est-ce que cette personne de
confiance sont est-ce que ces notions
sont connues est-ce qu'elles sont
appliquées ces directives
ont ici à donner ou pas
tu assistance respiratoire une dialyse
une alimentation artificielle des
notions pas forcément évidentes à
maîtriser
que je travaillais
donc c'est encore plus fou d'imaginer
des patients qui n'ont pas la moindre
idée de ce que peut être
la perspective d'un handicap aussi
sévère aussi lourd ou un séjour prolonge
rédimation puisse avoir un
arbitrage éclairé sur quelque chose dont
en fait ils n'ont pas la mesure moins de
10% des Français ont aujourd'hui rédigé
leur directives anticipées
seront peut-être des directives
anticipées
ce jour-là tous les services de
l'hôpital sont représentés réanimation
neurologiques pneumologiques et tous
souffre du manque de moyens dans le
service de gastro-entérologie beaucoup
de personnes en fin de vie atteinte de
cancer
un service de 30 litres c'est beaucoup
la nuit j'ai une infirmière et une
aide-soignante pour 38
donc autant vous dire que quand ne
serait-ce qu'un patient va mal et bien
c'est très difficile pour l'infirmière
et l'aide-soignante qui vont être seules
la nuit d'être présente d'être à
l'écoute de répondre à toutes les
demandes
un témoignage qui sera un des piliers du
rapport car remis la commission
d'évaluation de la loi claire et auditi
ce qu'on retient évidemment c'est
l'appel d'un certain nombre de soignants
c'est pour appliquer une loi quelle
qu'elle soit et celle-ci peut-être
encore plus que les autres il y a besoin
de ressources et il y a besoin de
ressources humaines
même si les députés n'étaient pas
mandatés pour se prononcer sur l'aide
activa mourir il conclut tout de même
comme l'avait fait le Conseil national
d'éthique que la loi actuelle n'apporte
pas de réponse à toutes les situations
de fin de vie notamment quand le
diagnostic vital est engagé à moyen
terme
[Musique]